take that off what are you genius
billionaire playboy philanthropist
which marvel film had a whopping 80 of
scenes unscripted
today we're taking a look at memorable
and hilarious marvel moments that were
made up completely on the spot
one mcu character named dropped a major
celebrity
any ideas why how did a very special
visitor contribute directly to a very
memorable improvised line
people walking around saying wakanda
forever
well good number episode 2 of the loki
series brings a very random yet
perfectly improvised line
remember loki's odd candy comment candy
have candy on asgore grapes nuts
you're so hiddleston came up with that
on the spot and it was just too good not
to make the final cut
director kate herron even highlighted it
as one of her favorite moments that
never fails to make her laugh
we are not doing get help director taika
waititi was super collaborative on the
set of thor ragnarok which was a pretty
big reason for the 80
of dialogue in the movie that ended up
being completely improvised
before shooting the brilliant get help
scene waititi suggested that chris
hemsworth and tom hiddleston do the
scene as if they were playing a game
from childhood
after exploring the idea for a bit the
scene was improvised from there
classic i still hate it it's humiliating
no not for me it's not
why td does credit hemsworth for coming
up with the idea of thor convincing loki
to go ahead with his plan
apparently beyonce exists in the mcu
at least according to dr strange himself
benedict cumberbatch
try me beyonce the beyonce reference was
tossed
in while cumberbatch was improvising his
way through the scene
wong said that for the most part he was
just listening and responding to
cumberbatch's instincts
the actors were really surprised by just
how hilarious the material they came up
with was
the moment was of course made even
better by having wong listening to
yancey for supposed research later on
and he transformed back into himself and
he was like yeah it's me and he stopped
me
thor's childhood snake story comes
directly from chris hemsworth
the actor had actually come up with a
number of different ideas in his improvs
but the snake memory wound up being the
perfect fit
so who would like to start while on set
for falcon and the winter soldier
anthony mackie and sebastian stan were
given the framework of how the therapy
scene should go but aside from that
the actors were left to their own
devices
i'm going to i know you are yeah the
result was a fantastic display of mackie
and stan's improv skills as well as
their deep knowledge and connection to
their characters
even small details like their
interlocking legs were natural instincts
only four or five takes were filmed at
each angle which is significantly less
than usual
just drink i like it i know it's great
right
the cast and crew were extremely
surprised to have thor
throwing his mug after requesting more
coffee the spontaneous choice proved to
be very popular with the marvel
president so
of course it made the cut seeing this
referenced in loki again is a great
moment
just going to show that sometimes these
golden improvs become part of the world
and we
love to see it
the crew of avengers infinity war got
quite the surprise when winston duke and
other actors in the film
started doing some chants in unison that
they'd never heard before
[Applause]
black panther was still in production at
that point so only the cast members who
were in both films knew what was going
on
the surprise moment turned out to be a
hit and made the final cut
having these appear in both films was a
great way to tie the movies together as
well
it's time no it's pretty surprising that
one of the most emotional scenes in all
of avengers infinity war was completely
improvised by the actors
vision's heartbreaking death scene was
actually ad-libbed by elizabeth olsen
and paul bettany
the actors knew where they had to go
with the scene so the director told them
to just
follow their instincts and we got the
magic that we see in the movie
we are out of time
i can't the actors were actually really
freaked out in the moments they were
filming realizing
just how much they were actually needing
to improvise
they wound up joking a lot together
making filming the scene a very fun and
silly process
this thing looked like coulson
talk like him too the moment that nick
fury peeks under the blanket on scroll
is pretty much gold and an idea that
came in the moment from samuel l jackson
director ryan fleck really enjoyed the
spontaneous move and after looking back
at the footage
the team agreed that it was too good not
to keep in the final cut
dance off bro me and you
chris pratt aka peter quill's real life
clumsiness came in very handy during
filming of guardians of the galaxy
he managed to bring this great moment to
life when he nearly dropped the orb
but it was actually completely by
accident
it ended up fitting the moment so well
though so the take was kept
and you've won congratulations
fair game karen gillan initiated a game
of paper football with robert downey jr
floating in space and the cameras
loved it so who is the paper football
champ
gillen has insisted that she was the
winner since she was the one that
started the match
i'm gonna sit here so you move the leg
in captain america civil war when robert
downey jr filmed this scene with tom
holland
his telling peter parker to move was
quite literally a direction
holland had forgotten his blocking so
instead of breaking character
the captain america actor pushed through
the scene and made what needed to happen
happen
the team loved it so of course it made
the movie
hey hey we know each other he's a friend
from work
this improv idea didn't actually come
from any of the actors
it was a suggestion made by a very
special guest on the set one day
a young fan from make-a-wish was talking
to hemsworth between takes and said that
thor should say hulk was a friend from
work
the actor took it seriously and brought
the funny line to life
that kid definitely has some good
instincts one of the most epic lines
that came up on the spot in the mcu was
definitely robert downey jr's
proclaiming
he was iron man and i
am iron man he completely surprised the
filming crew when he did it and brought
an extremely memorable moment to our
screens
we won mr stark when robert downey jr is
on set
brilliant improv isn't too far away his
final scene in avengers end game
was fully unscripted the team of course
laid out an outline and explained what
points needed to be hit in the scene but
otherwise downey jr and tom holland were
left to make improv magic together
holland said it was extremely emotional
to film especially with the small amount
of people that were actually present for
filming
nobody would know nobody
jeremy renner's sidebar teasing remark
at pietro while rambling to himself as
hawkeye was born in the moment
and renner committed so well it made for
one of the funniest bits in the whole
movie
one simple word change the meaning and
amped this line up to be one of the most
memorable snide remarks in avengers
infinity war
drax actor david bautista changed the
word where to why
and made movie magic with his line about
gamora who's gamora
i'll do you one better why is gamora
screenwriter christopher marcus was very
impressed with the improv and gives
total credit to bautista for it
i don't want to go i don't want to go
peter parker's final moments in avengers
infinity war was actually inspired by a
long improvisation the team had done
while shooting
in it they found the incredible moment
that holland has talking about how he
doesn't want to go and made sure to add
it to the movie
this emotional moment came from a simple
direction to just act like he didn't
want to go
and holland nailed it the avengers
post-credit scene that had the crew
eating shawarma in a half-destroyed
restaurant was totally inspired by one
of robert downey jr's improvised lines
in an earlier scene
have you ever tried shawarma there's a
shawarma joint about two blocks from
here
i don't know what it is but i want to
try it he threw the reference in after
taking care of loki and considering how
hard they were working
we wouldn't be surprised if the actor
was actually just hungry
evangeline lily and paul rudd punching
it out makes for a great scene in the
2015 film ant-man
but what makes it even better is red's
improvised lines
the ant-man actor regularly threw in
witty one-liners throughout the film
but one golden moment really stuck out
to us after being nailed by lily
rudd quips were you going for the hand
nice try ant man
we have a feeling her aim is pretty
accurate
that's how you punch the mcu movies are
definitely made that much better with
the actors who portray these heroes
it's evident in so many of these cases
that the actors are able to really
embody their characters and bring
hilarious and poignant moments to life
which was your favorite improvised line